>> Dana: CRIME IS A TOP ISSUE
FOR VOTERS AND COULD BE TIPPING
THE SCALES AMONG THE MOST
WATCHED SENATE RACES IN THE
COUNTRY.
DR. OZ PICKING UP STEAM IN HIS
SENATE RACE AGAINST DEMOCRAT
JOHN FETTERMAN IN PENNSYLVANIA,
A NEW FOX NEWS FORMAT HAS THE
FETTERMAN-OZ RACE NARROWING WITH
DR. OZ PICKING UP FIVE POINTS
SINCE JULY.
AND I SAID JEN PSAKI SAID, CRIME
IS A HUGE LIABILITY FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT IS SO BAD THAT JOHN FETTERMAN
HAS REMOVE MENTIONS OF BLACK
LIVES MATTER AND HIS SECOND
CHANCE PROGRAM OF HIS WEBSITE IN
THE LAST MONTH, ACCORDING TO A
REVIEW OF ARCHIVED WEB PAGES.
AND VIOLENCE HAS BEEN EXPLODING
IN THE STATE'S LARGEST CITY OF
PHILADELPHIA, MORE THAN 1700 PEN
SHOT AND HOMICIDES HAVE TAKEN
THE LIVES OF 400 PEOPLE SO FAR
THIS YEAR.
LARRY KRASNER RECENTLY CALLED
OUT BUT HE IS STANDING FIRM ON
HIS POLICIES.
>> THE REALITY IS --
>> THOUSAND PEOPLE KILLED AND 20
MONTHS.
>> IT IS WORKING.
THE REALITY IS WE LOOK AT ALL OF
THESE DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS WE
HAVE HAD A DEVASTATING BLOW FROM
THE PANDEMIC AND THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NO CORRELATION
BETWEEN BEING PROGRESSIVE OR
TRADITIONAL AND THE RATE OF
CRIME.
THESE STATES AND THE
UNITED STATES THAT HAVE A RATE
OF HOMICIDE THAT IS 40% HIGHER
ARE MAGA STATES.
THEY ARE TRUMP STATES.
>> Dana: THAT IS THE SAFE
HARBOR JUDGE, WHEN YOU ARE UNDER
FIRE, JUST GO TO TRUMP AND SEE
IF YOU CAN GET COVER THAT WAY.
>> Jeanine: FIRST OF ALL, THE
GOVERNOR DOES NOT CONTROL THE
POLICE IN INDIVIDUAL CITIES AND
IN INDIVIDUAL STATES, SO GET OFF
THE MAGA STATES, THAT IS NUMBER
ONE.
NUMBER TWO, THIS D.A. IS AN
IDIOT.
HE SAYS THERE IS NO CORRELATION
BETWEEN CRIME AND AN
AGGRESSIVE -- A TRADITIONAL
VERSUS A PROGRESSIVE D.A.
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU WHAT THE
CORRELATION IS.
THE PROGRESSIVE D.A. WANTS TO
LET THE CRIMINAL OUT.
THE TRADITIONAL D.A. WANTS TO
LOCK HIM UP AND THROW AWAY THE
KEY AND MAKE SURE THAT HE PAYS
FOR THE CRIME THAT HE COMMITS.
ALL RIGHT, THAT IS REAL SIMPLE.
SO KRASNER IS OUT OF HIS MIND,
JUST LIKE MIKE JARRETT SAID, A
THOUSAND PEOPLE KILLED AND SHOT
IN THE LAST 20 MONTHS AND THIS
GUY SAYS WE ARE IMPROVING?
IT IS LIKE LORI LIGHTFOOT SAYING
WE ARE MAKING PROGRESS -- NO YOU
ARE NOT!
YOU ARE MAKING EXCUSES, AND I AM
TIRED OF THE PANDEMIC BEING AN
EXCUSE OR A JUSTIFICATION FOR
CRIME.
IF IT IS, PASSED A LAW, MAKE IT
A JUSTIFICATION FOR A CRIME.
AND FINALLY, MY LAST POINT IS
THIS: THAT FETTERMAN, WHO WANTS
TO RELEASE SECOND-DEGREE
MURDERERS, PEOPLE CONVICTED OF
SECOND-DEGREE MURDER, HE IS A
BIG BLACK LIVES MATTER GUY,
WHICH KIND OF SURPRISING ME
BECAUSE HE TOOK A GUN AND CHASED
AN AFRICAN AMERICAN KID, AND
HELD HIM UNTIL POLICE CAME AND
DECIDED HE WAS INNOCENT, BUT
THAT IS A WHOLE OTHER ISSUE.
HE TAKES BLACK LIVES MATTER OFF
OF HIS WEBSITE, AND HIS PRESS
PERSON SAYS NO, WE DIDN'T.
THEY DID.
THEY TOOK IT OFF THE ISSUES
PAGE.
I HAVE THE ISSUES PAGE HERE,
THERE IS NO BLACK LIVES MATTER.
AND INSTEAD THEY INCLUDED IT
DOWN IN THE MIDDLE OF ANOTHER
THING ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE, AND
THEY JUST SAY BLACK LIVES MATTER
AND THESE COMMUNITIES MATTER.
>> Dana: HERALD, ONE OF THE
THINGS DR. OZ HAS DONE IS REALLY
FOCUS ON CRIME.
AND YOU HAVE FETTERMAN WHO HAS
HEALTH ISSUES, THAT WOULD ALSO
BE PLAYING A ROLE HERE, BUT HE
IS SMART TO GO INTO PHILLY
BECAUSE THAT IS A WHERE A LOT OF
THE PROBLEMS ARE, A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN PHILLY ARE FRUSTRATED
WITH KRASNER AND FOR SOME REASON
DR. OZ CAN EITHER GET PEOPLE TO
VOTE FOR HIM, GREAT, BUT IF HE
COULD HOLD DOWN THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE VOTING FOR FETTERMAN IN
THE CITY OF PHILADELPHIA, WHICH
ARE SO HUGELY POPULATED, HE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO WIN THIS RACE.
>> Harold: YEAH, THAT WOULD BE
THE POLITICAL STRATEGY, WITHOUT
QUESTION BE IF I WILL SAY THIS,
IN FAIRNESS TO THE CANDIDATE,
MR. FETTERMAN, HE IS A GUN
OWNER.
HE HAS FOR THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
HE HAS FOUR MAXIMUM PENALTIES
FOR VIOLENT OFFENDERS, WHICH
MEANS HE IS NOT FOR THESE SOFT
VEILED RULES WE SEE IN SOME
CITIES, INCLUDING OUR OWN CITY
HERE IN NEW YORK.
HE HAS BEEN SUPPORTED BY POLICE
OFFICERS ACROSS THE STATE
INCLUDING HE WAS THE MAYOR.
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO
HIGHLIGHT WHERE HE HAS BEEN ON
MANY OF THESE ISSUES.
THERE IS NO SURPRISE THIS RACE
WAS GOING TO TIGHTEN, IT IS THE
COMMONWEALTH OF PENNSYLVANIA, A
SEAT BACK ARE PRESENTED BY
REPUBLICAN NAMED PAT TOOMEY, AND
FETTERMAN HAS FOUND -- FOUND
EARLY ON IN THE CAMPAIGN THE
MESSAGING AROUND OZ NOT BEING
FROM PENNSYLVANIA AND IT SEEMS
TO RESONATE WITH VOTERS, IT IS
NOW COALESCING AROUND THREE OR
FOUR ISSUES HERE, AND WE WILL
SEE HOW IT MEASURES OUT.
I THINK IF YOU WERE TO ASK
VOTERS IN PENNSYLVANIA WHO THEY
BELIEVE IS GOING TO BE NICER AND
KINDER, WHO IS GOING TO BE MORE
SUPPORTIVE OF BLACK AMERICANS,
THEY WOULD PROBABLY STILL SAY
FETTERMAN.
I DO THINK IT IS HARD RECONCILE
HIM BEING SOFT ON CRIME IF HE
DID BELIEVE THIS YOUNG BLACK
MALE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
APPREHENDED UNTIL SOME QUESTIONS
WERE ASKED, I THINK HE WILL HAVE
TO ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS, BUT I
DO THINK IT IS HARD TO
CHARACTERIZE OR PORTRAY HIM OR
PAINT HIM SOMEHOW SOMEBODY SOFT
ON CRIME.
I DO KNOW THIS, HE IS A BIG
FELLA.
I KNOW I WOULDN'T WANT TO MESS
WITH HIM.
IF SOMEONE WAS PERPETRATING A
CRIME ON ME I WOULD RATHER HAVE
JOHN FETTERMAN THE DR. OZ.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: BUT JESSE -- GO
AHEAD.
>> Jeanine: WHAT ABOUT THE
FACT HE WANTS TO RELEASE
SECOND-DEGREE MURDERERS.
DON'T SAY HE IS TOUGH ON VIOLENT
CRIME.
>> Harold: THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> Jeanine: OH, IT'S NOT?
ALL THE ARTICLES AND REPORTS ARE
WRONG?
>> Harold: I HAVE NOT READ ONE
ARTICLE SAYING HE WANTS TO
RELEASE ANYONE CONVICTED OF
SECOND-DEGREE MURDER.
HE SAYS PEOPLE WHO SERVE THEIR
TIME --
>> Dana: DOES NOT WANT THEM TO
SERVE FOR LIFE.
I WANT TO GET JESSE AND GREG
INHERENT THAT PENNSYLVANIA TIES,
BOTH OF THEM.
THE POINT THAT OZ HAS MADE ABOUT
CRIME HAS LED JOHN FETTERMAN TO
BE VULNERABLE ENOUGH THAT HE DID
CHANGE HIS WEBSITE.
AND SO THERE IS AN IMPACT THERE
ON CRIME.
>> Jesse: RIGHT THERE
CLIMBING, GROWN MEN DON'T CHANGE
THEIR POSITION ON CRIME IN A
YEAR -- UNLESS YOU ARE A
POLITICIAN.
AND PENNSYLVANIA DOES NOT HAVE A
CRIME PROBLEM, AND PHILLY DOES
AND IT IS BECAUSE OF IDIOTS LIKE
KRASNER, WELL SAID, AND I BLAME
THE PHILLY VOTERS, THEY PUT THIS
GUY THERE, THEY KEEP REELECTING
HIM, BUT I ALSO BLAME THE
DEMOCRAT MACHINE BECAUSE THEY
GET IDIOTS LIKE THIS GUY
NOMINATED WHO ENDS UP GETTING
BLACK PEOPLE KILLED AND GETTING
DEMOCRATS KILLED AT THE POLLS,
SO YOU HAVE TO NOMINATE MODERATE
DEMOCRATS IN THESE DISTRICTS OR
ELSE IT IS GOING TO BE A
BLOODBATH, LITERALLY AND
FIGURATIVELY.
SO WE HAVE HAD SOME REALLY BAD
SENATE CANDIDATES, THE GUY
CRUISING FOR CHICKS IN MALLS
DOWN IN ALABAMA, THE WITCH,
REMEMBER HER, AND NOW
BETO O'ROURKE -- WASN'T HE A
CANDIDATE?
WHAT JOHN FETTERMAN HAS TO BE
THE WORST SENATE CANDIDATE THAT
I HAVE EVER COME ACROSS.
IS HE ON THE LIST FOR A HEART
TRANSPLANT, DANA?
HE SAID SOMETHING THE OTHER DAY,
HE SAID THE EAGLES ARE SO MUCH
BETTER THAN THE EAGLES.
I MIGHT EVEN AGREE WITH THAT,
BUT THAT IS VERY, VERY
CONFUSING.
HE LIVES WITH HIS PARENTS.
HE DOESN'T PAY TAXES.
HE HAS TATTOOS.
HE IS SO WEAK, HE WOULD BE EATEN
ALIVE BY CHINESE SPIES IF HE
EVER WENT TO WASHINGTON, D.C.
YOU COULD DANGLE RAW MEAT IN
FRONT OF FETTERMAN I JUST GO
LIKE THIS TO GET HIM A HOTEL
ROOM AND JUST HAVE YOUR WAY WITH
HIM.
THE GUY IS IN NO SHAPE TO BE A
U.S. SENATOR.
PURELY CHASES
BLACKS AROUND WITH SHOTGUNS, HE
WANTS TO BAN NATURAL GAS AND OIL
AND THE INTERNAL COMBUSTION
ENGINE.
THIS GUY IS NUTS!
HE WEARS GYM CLOTHES TO WORK,
DOES NOT OWN A SUIT, DRESSES
NICER -- PROBABLY WORSE THAN
BERNIE SANDERS.
THERE IS NO WAY HE COULD CUT IT
IN THE U.S. SENATE.
>> Dana: WORSE THAN
BERNIE SANDERS?
>> Greg: WELL --
>> Jesse: WHERE DO YOU GO WITH
THAT?
>> Dana: I
>> Greg: I THINK TOWHAT HAROLD K
HE HAS CHANGED, YOU PAINTED HIME
MODERATE THAN THE JUDGE.
I THINK HE HAS PROBABLY MAY BE
CLOSER TO THE JUDGE, HE FEELS
LIKE A COOKIE-CUTTER
PROGRESSIVE.
HE HAS SO FAR BEEN IMMUNE FROM
THE POLICIES THAT HE SUPPORTS
THAT DESTROYS THE STATE.
THE ONLY REASON WHY HE WAS
SUPPORTING BLM, IT IS NOT A
CONTRADICTION, IT WAS A
PROTECTION RACKET.
IT WAS BECAUSE HE CHASED THE
BLACK GUY WITH A GUN, SO HE
CHASED THE BLACK EYE WITH A GUN,
DID PRECISELY THE WORST THING
YOU CAN DO TO AN UNARMED
INNOCENT BLACK MAN AND WHAT HE
FIGURED, A JOGGER, AND WHAT HE
FIGURED, I WILL JUST SUPPORT BLM
AND THAT WILL GET ME COVERAGE.
THAT IS STARTING TO FALL APART.
HE IS A COUCH SURFING,
UNSKILLED, HOOD-WEARING DUDE WHO
LIVES WITH HIS PARENTS.
YOU KNOW, HE IS NOT QUALIFIED
FOR THIS JOB.
HOWEVER, HE COULD WIN, AND -- I
MEAN, IF HE WINS, THIS WILL GO
DOWN AS ONE OF THE MOST
EMBARRASSING REPUBLICAN BLUNDERS
IN HISTORY.
I WISH I HAD RUN.
I LIVED IN PENNSYLVANIA FOR TEN
YEARS.
THIS GUY, YOU KNOW, DR. OZ IS
LITERALLY BEING GIVEN THE SENATE
SEAT, AND HE CAN'T DO ANYTHING
WITH IT.
I THINK THAT